From the studio that finally learned how to
make Pixar movies
and the songwriting duo behind “Hasa Diga
Eebowai”
Comes the feature-length music video for “Let
it Go”--
FROZEN
It’s been three years since the last Disney
musical,
and 18 years since the last good Disney musical.
Now, the big D is back and adjusted for inflation,
with
Two princesses
two goofy sidekicks
and three different orphans.
Welcome to Arendelle, a magical-ish Scandanavian-ish
country that’s
been cursed with eternal winter
... even though their main export is ice.
Meet Elsa, a manic-depressive princess with
a confusing set of powers, like
Snow-blasting
Dress-making
Castle-building
And creating life?
"You're alive?!"
"I think so."
They kinda gloss over that one.
Fall in love with her adorkable sister Anna
Who spends 3 years of her adult life shut
inside a castle...
even though she could leave at any time.
"I can't live like this anymore!"
"Then leave"
And who could forget the completely unnecessary,
unexplained, magical
troll rocks?
When disaster strikes, watch Anna save the
day by teaming up with
Her sister
A merchant
A hot guy
And a snowman
To defeat...
Her sister
A merchant
A hot guy
And a snowman.
Experience a clever twist on past Disney films
that teaches girls they don’t need a prince
to rescue them, because all men are disgusting
loners
Greedy murderers
Or lying manipulative power hungry sociopaths.
"You won't get away with this."
"I already have."
Happy now, Jezebel?
So gather the family and sing along on a musical
journey that’s all
about the soundtrack.
Featuring unforgettable songs like
The exposition song!
The
song that sounds like it’s from Wicked
The romantic duet
The other romantic duet
The anthropomorphic sidekick’s comic relief
song
The one you skip
The one you don’t know the words to
And the YOLO song.
Starring...
Forgotten Sarah Marshall
Kristoff Waltz
Ugly Smurfs
Hans Gruber
Merchandising
and the wickedly talented Adele Dazeem
Frozen.
You don't need true love to thaw a frozen
heart:
Just soak it in water for a few hours.
Works on turkeys.
Hey, Screen Junkies
Can't get enough of my buttery voice?
Then check out Honest Game Trailers
over on Smosh Games.
Click the box to check out our honest take
on Mario Kart.
Screw you, blue shells!